police officers there public officials
with the power to use force against
civilians we'd like to believe that when
cops cross the line there's a powerful
system that police's the police now
we're all familiar with those dramatic
scenes when a cop gets out accountable
for his actions I'm gonna need you to
hand in your badge you go all right fine
you can have my badge and gun but we're
doing it in your office so I can slam
them down on your desk and yell out the
system stick but in reality we can
recount so few examples of an officer
actually being held accountable for
wrongdoing why because it's extremely
difficult to even investigate officers
for misconduct let's talk about that I'm
dreaming us and this is truth be told
complaining it's a police are routinely
ignored that's a conclusion Reuters
reached last year while reviewing
complaints from 15 cities they found
that very few were sustained by police
internal review boards and Tacoma
Washington for instance during the 12
months reuters investigated only 10% of
complaints weren't dismissed so why do
so many of these complaints get tossed
well it turns out someone is protecting
officers from accountability the police
unions like any Union police union serve
their members they negotiate fair pay
and workplace protections and when an
incident arises they're called upon to
help their membership the cops they
represent but unlike a lot of other
organized labor groups police unions
have managed to codify strong
protections for cops into law at the
expense of Public Safety in these 14
states police have their own Bill of
Rights policing and contracts also
include strong protections for their
officers in these 81 cities those
contracts include extremely specific
language aimed at protecting cops if
they find themselves being investigated
some of these protections might well
surprise you or maybe infuriate you but
they go a long way to what explaining
why it seems so rare that cops are held
accountable for wrongdoing in these
cities and states and officer accused of
improper behavior has allowed a
cooling-off period this means the
officers time between when they are
accused of misconduct and when they can
be interrogated by investigators that
one do have time shielding a cop for a
minute
the Gator can be 24 hours as it is in
Sacramento or can be up to 30 days as it
is in Louisiana normal citizens who are
accused of crimes aren't given a window
of time to collect themselves and get
their story straight
there's no cooling-off here for you or
me after all the first 48 hours are said
to be crucial to any criminal
investigation the cops know that there's
even a show glorifying that idea once a
police officer is finally interrogated
they've got protection is there too in
these cities in this state officers are
allowed to review all evidence against
them before interrogation and in 17
cities and 3 states
officers are even given the names of the
people who file complaints before they
can be interrogated and I've combined
these clauses effectively mean that
anonymous complaints can't be made
against an officer say you see something
illegal taking place and an officer is
done and you want to report it well
they'll immediately know who you are and
one of the nature of the allegation
before they can even be asked any
question now if you are are suspected of
breaking a law the police would you
start asking us questions and we can
request a lawyer to be present but why
did the police have protections that the
public doesn't shouldn't we hold public
servants to a higher bar even if an
investigation does continue after all
these rules around interrogations how is
that cop disciplined I guess what the
unions have rules to address that -
they're sometimes odd specifics about
the way an officer can be held
accountable for instance Portland's
Felicia in context states the city has a
reason to reprimand a discipline and
officer it shall be done in a manner
that is least likely to embarrass the
officer before other officers or the
public it literally says them and
there's also wiser practice of routinely
of racing police records of misconduct
in these cities and states police
departments erase disciplinary records
after a set amount of years sometimes as
early as one year the point is police
officers get special treatment how does
that make sense
now here's why this matters if the cops
aren't being held accountable how can
they hold communities accountable recent
polling shows that only 30% of black
people and 45% of Latinos have
confidence in the police this distrust
isn't good for law enforcement or the
public the police work for every
community in America they work for us
and we have a say in how they do their
jobs and what rules apply when they
cross the line police contracts and the
laws of protect cops and your community
are public and the contracts are
routinely renegotiated when they are the
police unions and your community are
going to be a strong voice in those
negotiations but they don't have to be
the only voice you can work with your
local officials to be at the table
[Music]